the Chinese have been in America for a
long time the Philips train tracks sped
its people and served in its military
we're just as American as everybody else
there's so much a part of America that
there are now more Chinese restaurants
than there are McDonald's Burger Kings
and KFC's combined but their experience
in the United States has been one of
exclusion once denied entry to this
country we continue to be
underrepresented in media and politics
in this series I'll take you to the
oldest Chinatown in America the fields
of the Mississippi Delta and the
sprawling suburban st. Gabriel Valley to
tell the story of the Chinese diaspora
in this country and how we use food to
fight exclusion and preserve our legacy
my favorite dish is ginger onion crab
since them my favorite dish is a shrimp
po-boy Union crossing over bridge
noodles Pororo Taiwanese stinky tofu
actually I'm kidding is Cantonese dim
sum for generations our food has been a
source of survival and resistance to
tell that story we ought to start in San
Francisco
underneath the restaurants trinkets and
fancy rooftops is a history of people
who've come to Chinatown in hopes of a
better life in America San Francisco
Chinatown is the oldest Chinatown in
America there are people here for fourth
and fifth generation Americans pretty
crazy for me because I'm second
generation which means that my parents
came here as immigrants and there are
Chinese people who have been here for
more than a hundred years they had the
best roast pork but now over across the
street at pork chop house they have the
best roast pork
this is Pam Talley whose family has been
here for over a hundred years I'm fourth
generation Chinese both my parents grew
up here in Chinatown their whole lives
they were surrounded by six
life was rough outside of Chinatown
racism levite people didn't want the
Chinese around so this neighborhood
became a safe haven for new immigrants
my mom would describe it often as
crossing beyond California Street
crossing beyond Kearny with going
outside of what was safety and
familiarity and so once you cross those
invisible walls you had to be on guard
the Chinese have been facing
discrimination since they first came to
the United States the first large groups
of Chinese men came because of the 18-49
boulders and they came primarily from a
very small area outside of the City of
Canton
that's Sumi she's going to help us
navigate the decades of history here in
Chinatown Chinese labor helped build the
American West
they built the railroads they worked in
in different factories so they were the
source of cheap labor many white workers
didn't welcome this at one point in 1871
an angry white mob of five hundred
people went to LA Chinatown and lynched
at least 17 Chinese immigrants elsewhere
Chinese were attacked
sometimes even murdered and China towns
were literally burned to the ground
over time the xenophobia led to the
Chinese Exclusion Act of 1882 the
Chinese Exclusion Act has the
distinction of being the only US law
specifically targets a racial group from
coming to the u.s. for the next 61 years
this law have Chinese laborers and
coming from the US and prevented those
who are already in the country from
becoming citizens voting or owning
property those who stayed in the US had
to find a way to survive during
exclusion it was very difficult for
Chinese to work outside of the community
so if you couldn't find a job but
somebody else you would start your own
business like laundries or restaurants
that's I ended up with dishes like chop
suey
well actually something that was made in
China it was invented by immigrants here
the dish shows both Americanized and
Chinese making both Chinese food and
both Chinese people a little less
threatening to American remember how
soon said most of the earliest Chinese
immigrants were from that tiny region
just outside of Canton well since the
exclusion act stops immigration
most of the people making food were from
a place the size of Delaware so what was
known as Chinese food like chop suey was
actually Americanized versions of food
from just one part of China once whoever
invented chop suey started serving chop
suey then they I think the expectation
of diners was that you go to a Chinese
restaurant you're going to get chop suey
Chop Suey and Chinese food really caught
on with the American crowd the number of
Chinese restaurants doubled from 1910 to
1920 in Chinatown became a destination
when the green 1906 earthquake hit San
Francisco the Chinese neighborhood was
left in ruins the area where Chinatown
located was totally burned to the ground
the city leaders at that time decided
haha here is our opportunity to rid this
area of the Chinese but the Chinese had
a different idea in order to preserve
Chinatown merchants rallied the
community and influence property owners
to rebuild the old neighborhood to look
like this these buildings made Chinatown
a tourist destination from food to
design surviving in America was
strategic from the beginning Chinese
would fight against the discrimination
that was perpetrated against them the
exclusion act ended in 1943 but for the
next two decades only 105 Chinese were
allowed into the u.s. each year
despite the network and resources that
Chinatown offered Pam's parents left
when they could finally afford to
growing up in Chinatown from my dad was
extremely harsh so having the
opportunity to move out was a kind of
fulfillment of an American dream for him
but for Pam her dream was to protect and
preserve Chinatown including its single
room occupancy apartments or SROs
housing meant for low-income residents
my grandmother lived in those kinds of
Aceros the cheapest rent would be at
that time those closest to the toilet
because that was where the smell was
really unbearable this is the one that
was directly the room was directly
across this from the toilet I have a lot
of memories about this that's like
living in here
and these very same Asaro still serve
Chinese immigrants today like ie and her
family of four who can only afford to
live in a ten by six room what is a
phone number they voted actually I'm
being honest artfully select house
Domingo Mohammed Al Pacino was a little
meta titles so you see that these cars
are really small and it's a crazy
contrast compared to the rest of campus
Cisco where you have houses that are
going for like $2,000 for studio
Pam's dedication to protecting tenant
rights in Chinatown started when she was
in college in the 60s back then as the
financial district was expanding the
International Hotel an SRO that house
elderly Filipino and Chinese residence
was set for demolition Pam and others
protested the eviction and were beaten
by police they lost the fight but the I
Hotel struggle became a symbol of unity
for many Asian Americans it was a place
that represented so much of who we were
as a community how we provided
affordable housing for those who work so
hard for America sacrificed their lives
left their families back home today as
rents have skyrocketed Chinatown is
threatened again by change what will
happen to a community that offers
everything from translation to legal
services for new immigrants is unknown
for the new immigrants if there was no
Chinatown what would it be like if there
is no Chinatown Yamoto
Chinatown near Tonopah Yana Korean car
don't know cuz I'm hope how long we'll
see one bingo bones out so you know
telling her to come sighted in whole
south
it's important to preserve a place like
Chinatown this is a space and where we
can take action and move together to
uplift each other's lives
the Chinese Exclusion Act is the first
and only major US law to have kept the
troop of people from coming based up on
their race we can still see signs of
this happening today if you enjoyed this
episode in San Francisco watch the next
video we'll be picking you to a
completely different place than
Mississippi Delta